[Musique]
ils donnent leur voix pour andy voit la
fédération nationale mais dans les
yvelines
elle a été fondée par joël le toullec
c'est une fédération de chorales de
personnes handicapées ou en situation de
handicap tous handicaps confondus et
toutes générations confondues et on a un
réseau de chorales sur à peu près 30% du
pays quoi à peu près un peu plus donc on
ne cesse de se développer d'année en
année ces jeunes artistes viennent du
conservatoire de lui mais il interprète
des chants de noël des classiques et des
créations plusieurs jours de travail
avec une concentration très importante
déjà ce qui est important c'était leur
dire que c'était pour un enregistrement
parce que je ne sais pas la même chose
quand enfin d'enregistrement d'un
concert quand on a un public bon le
public en temps et puis ça passe par
contre quand on a un enregistrement
c'est pas public qu'on a assez les
micros et les micros sont intraitables
une vingtaine d'artistes participent à
la création de ce projet parmi eux le
clae siens georges schmit virtuose de la
flûte de pan j'ai le bonheur pendant
plus de trente ans de faire des concerts
spectacles jeune public soit l'appel et
ça m'arrive encore d'en faire un jeu là
vous et avec plaisir je vais à la
rencontre de ses enfants
voilà je fais découvrir la musique
classique la musique tous styles de
musique à travers la flûte de pan
le cd sera disponible pour les fêtes de
fin d'année 2010 8 l'enregistrement
permettra de financer le festival
national de chorales de festival